Wes Anderson has long been interested in taking
meta-elements of storytelling and making them
part of the main narrative.
Whether it’s using curtains as a framing
device, using aspect ratio to denote periods
in time, or a book for narrative structure,
for Wes, any part of the filmmaking process
seems to have potential to be brought explicitly
into the story.
In Isle of Dogs he does this with translation.
Subtitles are something we usually consider
to be part of the film’s meta.
Like the posters, credits, or opening production
logos, they only exist to the audience as
a part of the information surrounding the
film, not as a part of the story itself.
But Wes is hard coding subtitles, translation,
and the audience’s ability to understand
characters directly into the movie.
This has it’s benefits and downsides, which
we’ll explore, but is this just a stylistic
quirk? Or if we dig below the showy exterior,
will we find actual thematic significance?
There’s an intrinsic perspective to a language
within a film that is relative to the audience.
In Isle of Dogs Wes chooses to use that perspective to his advantage
within the story.
In the film Japanese is spoken by most Human
characters, english is spoken by dogs, or
more accurately it’s stated that woofs and
barks are dubbed into english.
English speaking audiences understand their
communication without visible translation,
While most of the Japanese spoken in the movie
requires some kind of visible “in-movie”
translator.
Placing us in the dog's shoes contextually
The audience literally has to try to infer
meaning based on the behavior, and tonality
of the characters speaking Japanese, just
like a dog would have to, when trying to understand
a human.
It’s a brilliant way to create scenes where
the audience can suddenly and easily imagine
how a dog might feel, listening to a human
talk.
I think this was obviously a significant part
of the western director’s motivation to
set the story within a foreign context.
The alternative ways of creating this language
barrier between the dogs and humans would
be messy.
The dogs could speak their own language of
bark and growls, and this could have been
subtitled.
But that would do less to allow an immediate
identification with the dogs.
The dogs could speak english and the characters
could speak some type of gibberish, but this
may be too goofy and require a suspense of
disbelief too difficult for a lot of viewers.
The third option would be the Homeward Bound
option,
where both animals and humans speak english, but ostensibly can’t understand
each other.
This is also a bit awkward if used for more
than a few brief scenes.
Within the film, for Wes, the ability to understand
the other language, is linked closely to the
ability to empathize and advocate for the
dogs.
It’s not an accident that the character
that is one of the strongest advocates for
the dogs is a native English speaker.
Speaking the same language as the dogs, is
symbolic of an ability to empathize with the dogs.
The Tracy character exists because she’s
a character that would speak english, the
same language the dogs speak.
She’s there, not because an english speaking
audience needs that character, but because
she speaks english (the dogs language) to
the other members of the pro-dog resistance,
symbolically taking a position of advocacy
on the dog’s behalf.
Similarly, Atari has a device that allows
him to understand and communicate directly
with his dog.
This creates a connection strong enough that
he’s the only dog owner that tries to find
his dog on trash island.
I think a theme that’s buried here is that,
being able to understand another group makes
it harder or impossible to treat that group
inhumanely.
The odd types of on-screen translation Wes
chooses to use may seem like a stylistic quirk
at first glance.
But on closer inspection, there’s actually
a degree of realism embedded
in how he deploys translation.
In situations where no translation would be
available,
the audience usually doesn’t get any.
And in situations where we would have translation,
it is provided similarly
to how it would be in real life.
When watching an international news conference,
translation usually comes in the form of a
real-time vocal translator, not subtitles.
And when we’d be reading something in Japanese
if we could, we read subtitles in english.
And when we’re hearing a transmission from
a young boy,
another young boy is used as a translator.
While I think these techniques are clever
and unique, their unfortunate downside is
that they make the film’s perspective somewhat
anglo-centric.
What’s uniquely odd about Isle of Dogs,
is that even though it’s set in Japan,
it’s created for an english speaking context.
I was able to read quite a few translated
reviews from Japanese viewers, and while these
reviews were overall pretty positive, many
viewers noted the awkwardness and confusion
created in the process of translating the
movie back to Japanese.
The Japanese dub of the version has both the
dogs and the Japanese characters speaking Japanese
which completely destroys this scene,
where the device is supposed to enable communication
between the boy and his dog, they can seemingly
already understand each other in the dub version
since they both speak the same language.
And the in-movie translators simply become
useless dead-weight for the film
when translating it back into Japanese.
Use subtitles or a dub here, and the translator
and you're translating Japanese into English and then back into Japanese
Making the translator characters completely redundant
or leave the english
untranslated and let Japanese audiences try
to make out the Japanese lines in the background.
Neither solution is particularly elegant.
Because the Japanese lines are designed not
to be understood in the film by non-Japanese speakers
Wes felt free to leave some of those
lines muffled, or unintelligible.
This left some Japanese viewers straining
to understand lines that were never intended
to be understood.
And while all the Japanese characters quickly
flashing across the screen are just background
noise for other audiences, many Japanese viewers
reported
being distracted by trying to read everything.
The film’s thematic use of language is preserved
a little better for foreign releases where
the english can be dubbed. And the Japanese translated in a similar way to how it's translated in the English version
But because many of the English subtitles
are often a part of the actual physical animation,
changing them for every language would be
nearly impossible, and so in foreign versions
of the film, much of the text that exists
as a part of the world is left untranslated.
These translations often aren’t vital to
the story, but not having them does detract
from the experience.
But should the limitations of a technique
keep it from being implemented at all?
Should Wes have used different methods to
try to construct the perspective of the film?
As we discussed, every way of giving the dogs
a language the audience can understand carried
some downside.
And any film is imbedded in a cultural context,
for some films, like Isle of Dogs, that context
might be more integral to the story.
I, an english speaking American will never
be able to watch Japanese films in quite the
same way a native speaker would.
While a good movie can easily overcome the
limitations of experiencing it through subtitles
or (cringe) dubs, it does alter the experience.
And even if I learned the Japanese I still
wouldn’t have the same cultural context
a native speaker would have.
But should that stop filmmakers from using
that context to help tell stories in inventive
and interesting ways?
Isle of Dogs is an interesting case study
of this issue, because it doesn’t just use
another culture arbitrarily, it does so in
service of it’s story,
but in doing so it makes itself more anglo-centric.
I’m curious to know what you think in the
comments.
I don't think you can make any movie of a
cultural perspective, no matter what you do,
But should filmmakers try to minimize the perspective's impact on the story?
Or is it ok to use that perspective as a storytelling tool?
This video is sponsored by NordVPN.
By selecting one of the super fast NordVPN
servers in Japan, I was able to browse the
internet as if I was located in Japan.
This made it easier to do research on the
Japanese version of Isle of Dogs, and read
reviews left by Japanese viewers.
A VPN is crucial to have if you want to protect
yourself online.
NordVPN encrypts your traffic and lets you hide your internet history from snooping.
Like advertisers, your ISP, or the government.
NordVPN is the best VPN I've used and that's why I continue to use them.
You can choose from servers in over 61 countries
and be instantly secured and protected on
up to 6 devices at once including your phone!
And it's affordable!
NordVPN is offering my viewers 77% off 3 year
plans.
Just go to NordVPN.com slash thomasflight
or click the link in the description to sign
up and start protecting yourself.
That’s NORD VPN dot com slash t-h-o-m-a-s-f-l-i-g-h-t
and use the code thomasflight at checkout
and get started today.